kerik tricot infirmier anesthésiste à
l'hôpital chu henri-mondor à créteil
[Musique]
éric fricot bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors vous parlez de cette
tribune de médecins dans le jdd qui
s'inquiète du nombre de lire dans les
services de réanimation aujourd'hui avec
cette crainte de devoir faire un tri
qu'est ce qu'il en est au chu henri
mondor
tout d'abord en ce qui concerne le
nombre de lits de réanimation
bonjour merci de donner la parole aux
soignants la saturation on est on est
plus que saturé dans l'est dans les
hôpitaux et surtout dans les services de
rénovation
c'est une catastrophe j'écoutais le
d'éditos de monsieur poulin donc je vais
aller dans son sens c'est un désastre
sanitaire on a vu un confinement à 18
heures empêchant les ce soit les
soignants ou n'importe quel personnel
finalement et n'importe quel citoyen
d'aller faire ses courses et avoir une
hyper concentration de week-end et
surtout le samedi dans les magasins
parce que justement le confinement
faisait que les magasins étaient fermés
18h que même avait pris des dispositions
pour permettre à leur personnel de
rentrer chez eux de bonheur dont qui
finit il fermait à 17h30 le placent les
gens qui travaillent est arrivé à 17h30
18h s'était il se retrouver face à des
barrières et tous ces gens là se
retrouver en deep la concentration dans
les magasins malheureusement on voit
l'effet que ça a fait ça fait flamber la
le nombre de patients à prendre en
charge dans les dents les dans les
hôpitaux et dans les rayons et les
réalisations sont clairement saturé et
si on a d'un côté comment une prise de
position dans le journal du dimanche où
dans le monde
c'est bien pour expliquer le mal être
qu'il ya dans les hôpitaux etc ce
malaise
il est le résultat d'une politique
solitaire qui a été plus que désastreuse
oui et non dans le monde vous parlez
d'une autre tribune où effectivement les
les soignants disent que le emmanuel
macron devra assumer de faire le tri
c'est à dire d'envoyer des personnes à
la mort et de ne pas pouvoir les soigner
c'est assez dur comme comme injonction
vous pensez que c'est le cas il devra
assumer emmanuel macron amélie pas tout
seul à assumer je pense que c'est la
république la république en marche et
les députés aussi qui sont à l'assemblée
qui vont prêter allégeance à leur
président pourquoi je dis ça je sais on
est colère on ça fait un an
ça fait un an moi je me souviens d'avoir
fait une vidéo sur facebook où je disais
que les ministres avaient du sang sur
les mains
tout le monde a crié doivent faire du
populisme de vulgaires n'empêche que
c'était la réalité moi je suis soignant
ses longueurs métier je suis au plus
près des patients et les tous les
signaux d alerte que l'on avait crié
qu'on est en avait décrié qu'on avait
hurlé n'ont pas été écoutés et le
résultat la course
ben voilà vous avez une politique qui
vous dis très clairement fait avec les
moyens que vous avez parce que nous de
façon vous entendra pas plus je rappelle
quand même et je sais peut-être que le
parallèle il va être rapide je vous
rappelle que sous la présidence des
républicains avec sarkozy des
socialistes avec hollande est maintenant
de la république en marche c'est
l'équivalent de 100 belgique ont été
supprimés dans la fonction publique
hospitalière
cent mille dit je vous rappelle
simplement à combien sommes-nous de
décès coville
on approche la barre des 100000 voilà si
peut-être très simpliste de faire ce
parallèle mais n'empêche que c'est la
réalité et le quotidien des d'aidés
soignants dans les hôpitaux
oui c'est vrai qu'on a des bâtiments
c'est vrai qu'on a nous allons dans un
superbe bâtiment rbi
c'est vrai qu'il ya du matériel de temps
mais vous mettez kiki quel personnel
vous mettez et la stratégie on a
derrière c'est de faire des des
progressions massives
parce que le personnel qui est dit au
bloc opératoire contre les infirmiers de
bloc opératoire et les infirmiers
anesthésistes vont être heureux
mutualiser et re dispatchés dans les
réanimations pour faire face à la vague
salutaire qui nous tombe dessus
c'est hallucinant ça fait un an qu'on le
dit il nous faut du matériel et milou
faut du personnel surtout c'est du
personnel parce qu'on part déjà avec une
dette de personnel
rien n'a été fait je croyais moi je lis
m'a semblé voir lien
dernièrement sous mac ronces et 1400
lead réac ont été supprimés c'est pareil
c'est anormal c'est normal parce que
derrière il ya eu il parle en efficience
budgétaire il parle en économie il parle
avec des intérêts nous on parle avec de
l'humain moi je suis scandalisée de
cette politique sanitaire que l'on a
depuis plus de 15 ans elle est
dévastatrice
quand même débloqué 10 9 milliards
d'euros dans son plan pour le segura à
quoi ça va servir c'est rien c'est 10 9
milliards ils vont juste essayer de
récupérer le retard que l'on a sur les
autres pays
je vous rappelle quand même que le
salaire moyen d'al affirmiez sur les sur
les pays ocde de l'europe au niveau de
l' ocde
on est encore en dessous de la moitié
alors oui c'est vrai le gouvernement ait
fait un effort surhumain oui on va vous
donner 183 euros par mois c'est une
aumône s'est passé une aumône par
rapport au retard que l'on a je rappelle
que déjà sur la firme allemande à au
moins 300 euros de décalage donc voyez
on est en retard à chaque fois nous
donne une petite france c'est bête un
pansement sur une jambe de bois
c'est ni plus ni moins que ça la
politique de ce gouvernement je vous
rappelle quand même quand au delà de la
première crise on a un ministre qui a
démissionné la maintenance de la santé
chevalin là on a un deuxième qui est un
ver en effet ce qui peut mais et on lui
donne pas sûrement qu'on lui donne pas
les moyens mais en tout cas à nous dans
les hôpitaux et nous donne pas les
moyens moi c'est la première fois que je
vois autant de tribunes ce soit dans le
jdd où dans le monde chez lui ça fait
froid dans le dos
on nous on va nous mettre dans une
situation de crise comme si c'était en
pleine période des attentats qui avaient
ce coup les taris il ya cinq ans on va
se retrouver dans ce même cas de figure
avec des médecins qui vont être obligés
de faire des tris sur certains patients
et sont d'autres patients mais c'est pas
ça le système de santé en france c'est
pas ça c'est pas salé l'héritage que
l'on a du conseil national de la
résistance tant à pau à la sécurité
sociale et par rapport aux services
publics
merci beaucoup eric tricot d'avoir fait
mes yeux une question à les livrer en
brillant que c'est possible
heureusement juste un petit qu'on sache
c'est possible parce que je suis
infirmier anesthésiste de métier de
corps de métier et actuellement il va y
avoir un gars la loire liste qu'il en
train de passer à l'assemblée nationale
et qui a été rejetée au niveau du sénat
aussi on vous demande simplement c'est
un message pour les députés de tous les
députés de france d'aider tous les
députés en particulier des députés en
marche revoyez votre copie intégrer les
infirmiers anesthésistes en pratique
avancée c'est ce que faire au quotidien
et la preuve en est c'est que
actuellement on va être sollicité pour
revenir dans les réacs parce que notre
notre corporation et d'autres
connaissances paramédical fait quand on
a besoin de nous dans les réanimations
reconnaissez nous en pratique avancée
c'est vraiment un voeu pieux et si j'ai
un message à faire passer à tout le
monde mais aux citoyens et d'aidés
soignants vous avez applaudi à 20 heures
cette fois-ci jouer le jeu du
confinement
je sais que le gouvernement vous donne
pas les moyens de le faire mais prenez
sur vous rester confiné aidez nous à
passer sept vins qui va être
dévastatrices message merci eric tricot
je le rappelle vous êtes infirmier
anesthésiste à l'hôpital chu henri
mondor de créteil